There's one last form element I'd like to expose you to
before we move on to something else,
and this is for doing a Dropdown.
I'm going to get rid of this text here.
And a Dropdown has a form that looks like this.
It has a element, with a name--
we've been calling everything "q", so why stop--
and then it has a couple of elements.
So here I've put in a complete Select element.
We've got an opening and closing .
And the opening has the Name attibute equal to "q"--
which is what we've been using--
and then I've added 3 elements.
Each has the text inside it: one, two, and three.
Let's see how this looks in our browser.
Okay. So here we are in our browser--and now we see we have a Dropdown,
and it has a couple of Options.
And you can choose one of these Options--you know--
one, two, or three--and what I'd like you to tell me is what happens--
when I select "two" from the Dropdown and click Submit,
what appears in the URL?
Okay--so when we select "two" from the Dropdown,
what will the value of the "q" parameter in the URL be?
Go ahead and give this a try yourself.